hi guys in today's video we're going to
be covering football playing hand
transfers it'll help if you understand
pendulum swings if you haven't already
seen my video on that I'll post a link
in the description below also watch the
end this is a variation that I thought
that you might like to try okay so I'll
start this movement off with a pendulum
swing my hand stops at the base of the
pendulum and the momentum of the club
causes a rotation around my wrist the
transition through a point where the
club faces upwards where the laments
have continuing that they're called
carry on repeat this a few times and try
and let the club and carry on to do a
full pendulum swing the momentum of the
club should help you do this also try be
conscious of the three key points that
you're hitting which is left and right
and at the bottom of the swing so after
doing that a few times the movement
should be quite smooth here I'm doing it
from right to left at this moment in
time I'm not getting the other hand
involved so after getting comfortable
with that we can then look at changing
hands okay so this is now with my left
hand doing the movement going left to
right this is basically a mirror of what
was previously done from right to left
so once you're happy with that we're
going to look at transferring the club
so as I mentioned earlier the club will
transition through a point where it
faces upwards is that this point you
want to transfer to the other hand
repeat this process a few times where
you continue checking the alignment of
the club and also relax and try and feel
the momentum of the club as that should
be what's doing all the work as you can
see there's very little bend in my elbow
my arms are pretty much extended most of
the time
also I try roll my shoulders back and
open my chest out particularly on the
upswing otherwise this could cause
several shorter problems so this is a
full movement alternating between left
and right we'll have a look at it a bit
more in detail now close up as you can
see here the receiving hand goes
slightly higher than the hand holding
the club if it's done correctly the club
should feel quite light as it
transitions through the movement I've
slowed down the video so you can see a
bit more in detail if you watch here you
can see the transition point is when the
club's facing upwards
a lot of method you could use to learn
this is to create a larger circle in
front of you which gives you more time
to transfer from Hunter hunt as you
become more comfortable of this movement
you can tighten up the circle so
eventually your hand becomes the pivot
point this will also speed up the
transition to the other hand ok so I
already mentioned about the shoulders
being rolled back another thing to think
about is your plains and making sure
that they're straight you can see here
I'm leaning slightly forward and looking
down this can easily throw off your
plains so this can be rectified by
standing up straight and also spotting
the club on the left and right points as
I mentioned before you want to make that
plane as straight as possible this will
enable a smoother transition ok so just
to recap we've done an outwards version
of that movement there is also the
opportunity to do an in words variation
so as you can see here the pendulum
starts from across my body essentially
you just do the same thing but just in
Reverse to switch between variations you
can let the club swing without changing
hands and here you can see we're back to
the outwards variation which is
identified with the club that extended
outwards personally I don't use the
inward variation that much myself but
anyway never play with it let me know
what you think and as always thanks
again for watching
[Music]